and the running around yes I see I just  think if I was your attic on no  different  it was pretty tiring but now you know  I've done proper job so it's I used to  work at flower market so chatting to  people about a song ain't a killer on my  feet I actually sold you about a compost  Columbia Road flower market  I work there from 14 and I remember  seeing you and I sold you a pot I feel  actually carried it for you gave me a  tip thank God  this could happen well I think that's  the only bag of combos I've ever bought  I even sort of remember it my first job  selling bags of [ __ ] in the streets  under bruce'll  okay to call the 50p  so I'm running up shiny stairs exercise  yes but as if we're being recognized now  wait it's weird in selfies and ins is  quite rough so the same look you get  where someone thinks you're famous is  the same one they look at you with if  there were no jigna  [Applause]  [Music]  you